guten morgen aus aktuellem anlass haben
wir das thema dieser sternstunde
kurzfristig geändert der sieg des
70-jährigen immobilien milliardärs
donald trump über die demokraten hillary
clinton ist nicht nur eine politische
sensation sondern er bedeutet für viele
menschen gerade in europa einen
wahrhaften schock an den sich dunkels
der ängste und befürchtungen binden wie
ist trumps triumph zu begreifen was
folgt daraus für die zukunft demokratien
stehen wir im westen vor einer
politischen zeitenwende ernste fragen
für uns alle
ich bin sehr froh sie heute mit meinen
gästen besprechen zu können
der politologin patricia ganz den
literaturwissenschaftler hans ulrich
gumbrecht und in philosophen volker
gehrt herzlich willkommen frau lanz sie
sind wissenschaftliche direktorin eines
instituts für nachhaltigkeit und
demokratie transformationen sie haben
sich sehr viel mit partizipation und
bürgerbeteiligung beschäftigt ein buch
geschrieben die konsultative über
veränderungen in der demokratie und
angestrebte veränderung den letzten
beiden tagen nach der wahl habe ich mit
vielen menschen meiner generation
gesprochen und sie hat mir gesagt ich
habe zum ersten mal in meinem leben
angst angst um mein system eine
demokratie gar angst vor einem weltkrieg
können sie diese angst verstehen oder
haben sie diese angst vielleicht sogar
selbst ich habe diese angst nicht
verstehen kann ich sie ich denke es war
wirklich ein schwarzer mittwoch
aber ich denke wir sollten erstmal davor
zurückschrecken vorschnelle analysen zu
liefern und sozusagen auch deutungen und
daraus schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen die
vielleicht zu schnell sind und das ist
auch zu früh für einen abgesang des
westens ich denke dass es unklar ist was
jetzt passieren wird trump hatte
entweder den rängen spielen und die
märkte fans merkel zeigen dass sie ihnen
die richtung sozusagen das annehmen oder
aber es kommt zu größeren
ausschreitungen wie die demonstrationen
in amerikanischen städten gezeigt haben
und es kommt zu wahrhaft demokratischen
umbrüchen darin liegt aber auch eine
chance ich glaube das system ist an
seine grenzen gekommen und auch das
wirtschaftliche system und diese
umbrüche sind auch dazu da sozusagen
neues zu entwickeln
und ich glaube dass es auch möglich ist
allerdings müssen wir es aushalten diese
offenheit aushalten noch nicht zu wissen
wie das neue system aussehen soll
und ich glaube dieser situation befinden
wir uns und angst ist kein guter
ratgeber
franz herum recht betont jetzt die
umbruchsituation die offenheit sie
lernen seit fast drei jahrzehnten in
stanford das literaturwissenschaftler
sind in deutschland geboren
seit 2000 sind sie amerikanischer
staatsbürger wie sind sie am mittwoch
nach der wahl aufgewacht als amerikaner
mit dem satz vielleicht nächstes
nordamerika also ich war
eigenartigerweise auf einem flug von
washington nach frankfurt und der
kapitän der maschine sei man als mit
maschine rein kam war er vor amerikaner
und sagte er würde vor der landung in
frankfurt uns mitteilen wie stehen
mittlerweile und es kam keine botschaft
von den piloten und das war natürlich
angesichts des verhältnisses von reagan
zu den afrikanern umgekehrt sehr
schlechtes zeichen ich habe den laptop
noch einmal angeworfen und sah dass
hillary keine chance mehr hatte und ich
wollte mir eigentlich den satz ins
gehirn himmelbett cannot be true weil
ich nicht damit gerechnet hatte und
merkte aber dass ich auf einer vor
bewussten bei summe so formulieren kann
eigentlich damit gerechnet hatte also
das ist eine dynamik abzukommen
vielleicht beschreiben die ist auf der
seite von hillary clinton nie gegeben
hat
die zumindest das nicht wie eine
überraschung aussehen dies also ich war
weniger überrascht als ich erwartet
hätte er gehabt sie sind senior
professor für philosophie für praktische
philosophie und sozialphilosophie an der
humboldt-universität sie haben sich
gerade in den letzten jahren intensiv
mit fragen der öffentlichkeit und der
veränderung des öffentlichen
bewusstseins beschäftigt und sie sind
ein kenner der aufklärung aufklärung das
bedeutet auch nach kant auszug aus einer
unmündigkeit bedeutet volkswille
souveränität ist für sie diese wahl ein
ausdruck einer souveränen mündigen
volkswillens wir müssen es erst einmal
so nehmen wenn wir nicht die demokratie
mit ihrem mechanismen in frage stellen
wollen aber
diesen auszug wie sie sagen aus einer
selbst verschuldeten unmündigkeit ist
von kant ja zunächst mal verwendet um
den einzelnen anzusprechen
der soll den mut haben sich seines
eigenen verstandes zu bedienen und das
ist denke ich ein wahlspruch der auch
die amerikanische verfassung betrifft
man one man one vote ist ja genau dieser
punkt wo man davon ausgeht dass jeder
für sich aufgeklärt ist und seine eigene
entscheidung trifft und das muss man
heute natürlich selbstverständlich auch
auf die frauen übertragen
aber wenn man von dieser position der
aufklärung ausgeht dann denke ich muss
man sehen dass das eine zu enge fassung
ist
wir müssen sehen dass der einzelne auch
eingebunden ist in einen systematischen
zusammenhang und dass er sich auch so
versteht und da hat sich natürlich
inzwischen außerordentlich viel
verändert es geht um die voraussetzungen
dafür dass jeder auch tatsächlich sich
seines eigenen verstandes bedienen kann
und es geht um vielfältige sie haben
doch gerade angesprochen kommunikations
bedingungen die diese selbstständigkeit
im eigenen urteil auch tatsächlich
fördert und da habe ich den eindruck
gibt es uns viel zu nach wenn ich bin
völlig ja meinung dass wir nicht
vorschnell urteilen und keine
vorschnellen angst mahnen
schlussfolgerungen ziehen
aber es gibt doch gewaltige aufgaben
nach dieser entscheidung bleiben wir mal
bei dem one man one vote man könnte
sagen der politik geht es auch aus
kandidaten sicht und personalisierung
unvernunft in diesem kandidaten
das war nun ein kandidat der mit allen
vernunft regeln ganz bewusst gebrochen
hat und es war ein kandidat der eine
paradoxe identifizierung mit seiner
wählerschaft hatte er hat eine
deklassierte weiter weise wählerschaft
angesprochen als ein sehr gut erzogener
millionärssohn und milliardär
wie funktioniert so eine identifizierung
von armen deklassierten menschen mit
einem anderen menschen der ihnen helfen
sollte ja gar nichts mit ihrer
lebenswelt zu tun hat von 1
hat es geschafft die weiße
arbeiterklasse hinter sich zu bringen
und man konnte er sagen normalerweise
gab es ein klassenkampf der davon
profitierte dass man eben menschen
gewählt hat die ihre interessen
durchgesetzt hat so war die idee auch
und auch sozusagen deskriptive
vielleicht sie repräsentiert hat das ist
bestimmt nicht weil er selber nicht aus
der arbeiterklasse stand und auch
sicherlich sozusagen durch sein
verhalten ja auch nicht gerade gezeigt
hat dass er durch steuerhinterziehung
und in dem er seine seine eigenen
mitarbeiter wenig entlohnte ttr
hoffnungen machen konnte genau diese
sorgen die ökonomischen sorgen
vielleicht in den griff zu bekommen
eine verschiebung stattgefunden denke
ich von so was wie einen klassenkampf
auf ökonomische ungleichheit auf eine
abwehr des fremden eine eine identität
politik die nicht nur ökonomisch ist und
aus frankreich hat dass die eine police
notwehr genannt weil sozusagen auch ein
kurzschluss ist und man muss erst mal
verstehen warum diese globalisierungs
ängste sich um münzen inhomogenität
vorstellungen und angst vor dem fremden
angst vor der welt draußen
ich denke es hat auch was mit zeit
regime zu tun dennoch darauf zu sprechen
kommen später - seite stehen aber damit
zwei stichworte klassenkampf
globalisierung das sind begriffe die in
der europäischen labor an der politik
eine große rolle spielen in amerika hat
auch eigentlich gar nicht so herum
reicher leute willigt er redet hat es
gibt natürlich intellektuelle in amerika
das wort klassenkampf wenn und ich habe
gerade ein marx seminar gemacht wenn man
das wort klassenkampf hat es in der
geschichte der usa je eine situation
gegeben die man im ernst und nicht nur
in einem allzu weiten sinn klassenkampf
nennen könnte ich denke eigentlich nicht
es hat natürlich so kämpfe spannung
auseinandersetzungen zwischen bestimmten
ethnischen gruppen zwischen bestimmten
mann artis gegeben aber eine
konfrontation dessen was marx das
kapital genannt hat mit der
arbeiterklasse denke ich hat im sinn der
europäischen
tradition nach meinem wissen so nie
gegeben
man kann natürlich immer soziale
spannungen so interpretieren die frage
herr einberger wie es kommen können dass
sich leute die wirtschaftlich in einer
situation sind die so prekär ist dass
man sich das in europa in europa des
wohlfahrtsstaats kaum vorstellen können
sich mit jemandem mit trump
identifizieren ist glaube ich für
amerika leicht zu beantworten weil man
und das ist teil eines american dreamz
noch am leben ist weil man glaubt dass
man vielleicht morgen auch an mir der
ist ja weil man an schicksals wänden
glaubt weil man sich auch in einer
situation die prekär ist woran ich weiß
mit nächsten tag etwas zu essen hat es
könnte aber auch sein dass man am
nächsten tag plötzlich das große glück
macht ja also ich hab das während des
wahlkampfs nie als eine besondere
überraschung erlebt dass ich diese
deklassierte klasse diese deklassierten
sozialen gruppen gerade mit trump
identifizieren also ich würde sagen die
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht eher umgekehrt
das typisch zu sagen das ist nicht
spezifisch amerikanisch berlusconi was
genau aber es ist natürlich sie auch so
wir sollten uns nicht nur das ergeben ja
auch die wahlanalysen jetzt auf die
weißen deklassierten sehr viele college
educated sehr viele mittel und auch gut
einkommen menschen mit gutem einkommen
haben trump gewählt und sieben von zehn
trump wählern sagen sie würden das
amerika der 1950 er jahre zu dem
jetzigen bevorzugen
für jemanden der als aufklärer in die
zukunft denkt und die zukunft als
gestaltungsraum sieht kann es eine
unglaubliche sehnsucht nach einer
vergangenheit zu geben in diesen wahlen
es ist ja so dass die veränderungen die
die gesellschaften jetzt in den letzten
10 20 jahren durchmachen eben ein sehr
offenes ende haben und auch von sehr
vielen mit sorge betrachtet werden und
natürlich auch schon mit wirklich
einschneidenden folgen verbunden sind
was zum beispiel die arbeitskräfte
situation die qualifikation für das was
jetzt gefordert es angeht
und insofern hat sich in der tat
bereits viel verändert und es ist
absehbar dass ich noch sehr viel mehr
verändert und wie ich meine auch
verändern muss um auf die neuen
lebensbedingungen zu gehen und da ist es
natürlich schon verständlich wenn man
den traum von einem früheren leben wo
alles geordnet schien wo alles eben
einen aufbruch versprach und das für
amerika die nun wirklich anerkannte
weltmacht besser ging
diesen traum gerne noch weiter träumen
möchte aber es war auch die 950 jahren
am er keine zeit in der die schwarzen
noch nicht wählen durften in der die
frauen noch nicht initiiert waren auch
wirtschaftlich nicht in diese kulturelle
starke hegemoniale stellung des weißen
mannes gab wird das alles auch
zurückgewünscht im moment ich glaube
nicht dass es teile vorstellung ist also
wenn man versuchen kann sich
vorzustellen was sich solche leute
vorstellen ich würde nicht
unterstreichen was sie gesagt haben ich
unterstreicht was sie gesagt haben es
sind nicht nur die ärmsten die sind es
auch es sind generell leute sich
deklassiert füllen das kann auch jemand
sein dann herbert abschluss hat und aus
dem harvard abschluss nicht das gemacht
hat bei seine familie und er erwartet
haben ja das wäre auch eine art
deklassiert zu sein auch wenn man zwei
oder 250.000 dollar im jahr verdient
also es ist die frage sozusagen das sich
hoffnungen nicht erfüllt haben
es ist richtig was sie sagen dass das
der traum von einer historischen epoche
amerikas ist in der schwarzen nicht
wählen konnten
ich glaube aber nicht dass die explosion
der schwarzen teil dieses traums ist ich
glaube dass diese deklassierte
bevölkerungsgruppe weniger rassistisch
ist als man in europa immer so leicht
ihn sagt das ist nicht teil der energie
die mögen de facto sich so verhalten
aber ich glaube dass ich nicht alles
traum sein wenn ich an die 50 jahre wenn
ich mir die 50 jahre vorstellen sich
diese leute vorstellen und ich bin einer
von den beiden hier am tisch die
erinnerungen an die 50er jahre haben
dann sieht dass die 50er der petticoat
der milliardär milchshakes und der zeit
es ist weil das vertrauen unsere kleine
stadt ja wo alle am sonntagmorgen in die
kirche gehen und wo scheidung 2
gesetzlich möglich ist aber als
lebensform nicht möglich ist wo jede
familie drei oder vier kinder hat wo das
leben ohne druck eine notwendigkeit hat
ich höre sie oft heute in den
vereinigten staaten das wort ein need
something to hold a
und ich glaube das ist die sich an einer
gesellschaft ja auch wird gewissheiten
aber gewissheiten die gar nicht
versprochen werden müssen das war ein
einfaches leben hier und es war
natürlich die ganz kurze zeit in der
geschichte der usa als die usa auf der
einen seite sich bewusst waren eine
weltmacht zu sein
und wo diese weltmacht rolle außer durch
die ideologie der sowjetunion im westen
nun frage gestellt und intern überhaupt
nicht in frage gestellt wird recht geben
es war natürlich auch eine welt in der
die komplexität viel reduziert da war
als heute dennoch denke ich dass amerika
ich würde die witterung auf das event
legen das ist eine sehr große
rückwärtsgewandtheit auf die
vergangenheit bezogen und sicherlich es
geht nicht darum was stand natürlich
verkörpert hat dass jeder auch jemand
aus dem white trash auch plötzlich
millionär sein könnte sondern über nacht
sondern auch dass er in gewisse
sicherheits vorstellung gegeben hat die
ansonsten nicht verfügbar sind
allerdings rückwärts gewandt und die
frage ist inwiefern motivationsfähigkeit
die beschleunigungskraft überhaupt
wieder gewinnen um alternative
zukunftsvorstellungen die tragfähig sind
zu entwickeln
ich glaube darum muss es gehen und
deshalb erfordert natürlich auch eine
gewisse offenheit und sozusagen eine
gewisse grundsicherheit diese offenheit
überhaupt auszuhalten denn wir haben
noch keine genaue vorstellungen wie es
in zukunft laufen
wir wissen nur dass mehr vom selben
nicht zielführend ist aber eine gesamt
kulturelle verunsicherung können wir
sagen komplexitätsreduktion durch
einfache lösungsangebote das sehe ich
alles weil wir können ja nicht übersehen
dass es stark rassistische stark
fremdenfeindliche stark frauenfeindliche
töne in diesem wahlkampf gab von denen
alle glaubten jetzt ist hertrampf als
kaya erledigt mitnichten
sie scheinen ihn samt getragen zu haben
ich glaube dass also nochmal ich will
jetzt nicht in trump in irgendeiner
weise verteidigen
ich glaube dass diese tabubrüche die new
york times hat 20 schwellen
identifiziert und das kann ich hab' ich
kann ich nachvollziehen ich das lese und
dachte jetzt habe definitiv ins
fettnäpfchen getreten und es kandidaten
und es jeweils herrscht gestärkt
hervorgegangen ich denke die tabubrüche
sind auch insgesamt in kohärenter wenn
es modisch gewesene und nord politik
korrekt hätte auch sozusagen also werner
keller englisch also das englisch der
schwarzen sprechen können wenn es an
tabubruch gewesen wenn es ging um die
tabubrüche es ging zu zeigen ich lasse
mich von der politik correctness nicht
einschüchtern
es ging darum nicht so zu reden als er
mental der politischen klasse
ich glaube dass der rassismus nicht
zentral weil es gibt ein in korea system
und das find ich signifikant es gab sehr
starke statements von frank wenn das
gepasst hat wenn er wusste dass also im
publikum
kappes und homosexuellen sind und es gab
ganz starke enthalte also homovics
statements und ich denke das ist das ist
das problem an trump das trump mit einer
rhetorik die nur auf resonanz abzielt
diese inkohärenz ja vielleicht wahrnimmt
aber die in karenz ist für ihn kein
problem und das problem ist dass es kein
problem für das muss er den philosophen
besonders besorgen das inkohärenz
programmatisch wird und dass damit auch
verlässlichkeit in der ansprache
verloren geht ja natürlich also
konsequenz und berechenbarkeit und
darauf gegründet daneben auch eine
entsprechende verantwortung im
politischen amt oder auch in dem was man
verspricht sind essentielle
voraussetzung
und ich sehe dass auch meine
gesprächspartner beobachten dass alles
dies im wahlkampf nicht gegeben war und
dass trump nicht geschadet hat und ich
denke wir dürfen auch nicht sagen weil
eben bei seiner gegenkandidatin eben die
identifikation mit etwas das man leiht
war ebenso groß war und eben diese
identifikation ab
lehnt wurde dass man allein aus diesem
widerstand gegen das was hillary clinton
repräsentiert hat den erfolg von fram
nicht erklärt ich kann nur sagen dass
wir jetzt nicht wie sich das in den
kommentaren abzeichnet davon ausgehen
sollten wir dürften diejenigen die
dagegen gestimmt haben was eigentlich
von der demokratie zu erwarten ist jetzt
nicht mehr belehren wir sollten ihn
nicht mehr moralisch kommen es kommt ja
aus sehr vielen kommentaren jetzt heraus
sondern es ist richtig wir sollen nicht
von oben herab urteilen wir sollten
jetzt nicht die besserwisser spielen
sondern uns um die situation kümmern in
der sie sind und die sie dazu gebracht
haben so zu denken
aber wir können nicht darauf verzichten
aufklärung zu betreiben auf die wie wir
meinen das ist natürlich immer nur eine
vermutung und mir ein sicheres wissen
auf die wahren ursachen bestimmt der
schwierigkeiten und zum beispiel auch
darauf dass es diese sicherheit die es
vielleicht in den 50er jahren ja auch
nicht bei allen aber bei einigen gegeben
hat dass es diese sicherheit im leben
eigentlich nie gibt ich glaube dass es
seine aufgabe die ein philosoph
mindestens in politischen situation
haben sollte oder aber deutlich machen
sollte um klar zu machen dass dies immer
ein wagnis ist in einer offenen
gesellschaft zu leben und dabei es auch
auf einen selbst ankommt wie man damit
umgeht damit will ich aber nicht davon
absehen dass die bedingungen die
rahmenbedingungen in einer gesellschaft
gelegt werden müssen
und da denke ich hat es in amerika an
einigen gefehlt so dass man durchaus
verständnis haben kann
für die lage vieler die dieses system
wie sie meinten dann auch abgelehnt habe
doch noch als 1 kommentar das man
schätzt also die die tram wähler 60
millionen trump hat 20 bis 25 millionen
sind leute die vorher nicht zu wahlen
gegangen sind und die in der einen oder
anderen weise sich für deklassiert
halten und man muss wirklich sehen es
gibt ja auch ein memory tierheim in den
usa also jede kleinste klasse also
jemand der sich um dich kümmert und eine
an
diese reicht bis zum entweder
tatsächlich objektiv schlecht geht oder
die sich aus plausiblen gründen für
deklassiert halten die haben keine lobby
ja die haben keine lobby weil sich weil
es riskante sich mit denen zu
identifizieren weil es riskant ist die
bedürfnisse die es gibt dieser leute zu
artikulieren und das ist keine einfache
frage also was wir intellektuellen zu
sagen hätten zu empfehlen hätten das ist
relativ klar aber wie man diese gruppe
erreichen können ohne nur auf resonanz
auszugehen
und wie man es schaffen kann zu dieser
gruppe zu reden ohne herablassen zu
wirken das ist denke ich ein ganz ganz
großes strategisches problem nicht
gleich nachfragen man könnte sagen es
ist ein anerkennungs problem könnte man
für diese menschen fühlen sich nicht
anerkannt wie findet man eine sprache
der anerkennung die einerseits
aufklärend ist und andererseits nicht
diese elitäre belehrung verkörpert die
gegen die ja große allergien besteht
offenbar also zum teil ein problem der
sprache sicherlich und ich glaube das
ist auch eine liebe problem ist wenn ich
die sprache gefunden haben
aber ich würde noch mal zurück gehen
sicherlich sind es die subjekte und es
ist das individuum was sich natürlich
diesen aufklärerischen sagen und bühnen
unterziehen muss aber gemeinsame und ich
glaube darum geht das gemeinsame
weltordnung weil die welt ist uns
abhanden gekommen im augen
die können wir nur gemeint
leisten die können wir nicht allein
leisten der job der mir in den gliedern
sozusagen noch steckt seit mittwoch ist
der dass keiner meiner freunde bewusst
vor bewusst vielleicht schon aber
bewusst angenommen hat wie auch die
ganzen umfragen dass trump gewinnen
würde ein einziger freund der übrigens
ein sehr politischer ingenieurs
wissenschaftler aus portugal hat es
gesagt alle anderen von meinen freunden
haben gesagt das wird nicht passieren
und das zeigt dass hier selbst
vielleicht ein echo kammern uns befinden
und unsere sozusagen die die welt er
eine vorstellung im wille ist als als
eine vorstellung und schon eine eigene
nase packen müssen ob wir denn wirklich
so zu sein genau genug zugehört haben
und noch mal zum 12 frage der
anerkennung
es geht auch um mehr als nur zuhören ich
glaube es geht wirklich darum letztlich
arenen wieder zu öffentlichen reden
wieder herzustellen
wo eben es nicht nur darum gehen muss
was auch schon ein guter schritt wäre
wertevorstellungen und und sozusagen
werte konflikte und unterschiedliche
wertvorstellungen überhaupt abzugleichen
ich glaube wir müssen erstmal ein
weltverständnis wieder gemeinsam
herstellen das ist ein fundamentaler
bedeutung krise die wir eigentlich haben
und dafür gibt es keine oder
unzureichende öffentliche räume es gibt
allerdings schon in auf der
gesellschaftlichen ebene sozusagen vor
staatlichen ebene jedenfalls in europa
aber sicherlich auch in den usa ein
humus annan zusammenhängen an engagement
was wir jetzt gerade auch in der
flüchtlingskrise in deutschland gesehen
haben was es zu nutzen gilt was die
politik noch nicht geschafft hat zu
übersetzen ja so ein engagement gibst du
dich in usa auch aber zum beispiel den
usa aus meiner eigenen erfahrung dort es
gibt ja zum beispiel etwas was in europa
so nicht mehr gibt die gemeinden die
kirchen als begegnungsräume als
diskussions räume als räume der
gegenseitigen anerkennung über gewisse
differenzen hinweg und auch gerade diese
kirchlichen religiösen gruppen
mehrheitlich für trump ja es gibt also
es gibt dass es gibt zum beispiel auch
was man n
ja also in überflutungs situationen also
kalifornien wo ich wohne ist darauf
nicht vorbereitet ins drei tage rechnet
sind irgendwelche basement überflutet
und das ist nicht nur dass die leute
sehr hilfreich sind und dann nicht
diskriminieren also jedem helfen wollen
und ich würde gerade zu sagen dass meine
landsleute die situation lieben diese
dramatischen situationen wo man sich für
andere engagieren kann überlegt die
brave boots angezogen und das macht also
spaß es gibt ein gewisses potenzial
die frage ist wie man diese trump wähler
erreichen kann ohne von oben herab zu
sprechen ich will ein beispiel nennen
das ist ja wie das sind also das ist ich
rede von einem restaurant was auf eine
klientel von jungen millionärin auswahl
und dann habe ich den besitzer gefragt
das restaurant gefällt was ist
eigentlich die formel oder hat er gesagt
wir möchten junge millionäre anziehen
die gut essen wollen ohne dass man sie
belehrt wird laut weichert ja also das
ist sehr interessant
das sind jetzt noch ökonomisch enorm gut
geht die sich aber auch deklassiert
füllen
ja die gerade in der nähe von stanfour
nicht beständig also der summe jetzt
erzählt den keine langen geschichten
über die familie des weinproduzenten
sondern sie wird den guten wein und wenn
sie eine frage haben reagierte darauf
und ich denke das ist eine situation die
man eben auch in der politischen
ansprache ermöglichen sollte und das ist
nicht einfach und verlangt
möglicherweise an tramper tigges
charisma von jemandem mit anderen werten
ein beispiel dieses charismas und auch
ein beispiel für die suche nach einer
sprache die nicht spaltet oder 1 hat
seine acceptance speech also die rede
nach dem wahlausgang gegeben und da
schauen wir jetzt mal kurz ein
einspieler dazu an donald trumps großer
auftritt vor seinen jubelnden anhängern
als gewählter präsident
in seiner ansprache gibt er sich
versöhnlich nichts erinnert in diesem
moment an den provokateur aus dem
wahlkampf
es ist nun zeit für amerika die wunden
der spaltung zu heilen allen
republikanern
demokraten und unabhängigen im ganzen
land sage ich es ist an der zeit für uns
als ganzes volk zusammen zu kommen
donald trump tritt tatsächlich präsidial
auf keine seitenhiebe keine
beleidigungen gibt er vor seinen
anhängern von sich macht aber sehr wohl
große versprechen wir haben einen
großartigen plan für unsere wirtschaft
wir werden das wachstum verdoppeln und
die stärkste wirtschaft der welt haben
gleichzeitig werden wir gut mit allen
nationen auskommen die gewillt sind mit
uns auszukommen
kein traum ist zu groß für uns keine
hürde zu hoch
nichts was wir uns für unsere zukunft
wünschen ist unerreichbar
amerika wird nach nichts weniger als dem
besten streben empfehlen wollten aber
ganz ehrlich nicht es geht einfach darum
dass gerade wenn man die so zitiert hat
wenn man eben gestaltet hat dann ist es
denke ich
befreiend lösen man hat man den eindruck
man könnte vieles hinter sich lassen
wenn davon einigkeit von verständigung
und eben auch von dem was man vor sich
sieht als aufgabe auch der verfassung
und des amtes spricht das halte ich für
einen wichtigen punkt dass man einigkeit
betont aber das ist doch zugleich auch
bei dem programm mit dem er angetreten
ist das problem
wir können die unsicherheit die in der
welt herrscht denke ich nur auflösen
dadurch dass wir von vornherein auch an
die einigkeit appellieren an die
schicksalsgemeinschaft in der die
menschen insgesamt stehen es geht nicht
nur um die amerikaner und dass jemand
auftritt dann eben plötzlich amerika
wieder so verbinden will
aber damit erkennt dass er ganz
bestimmte andere sprachspiele auch
beherrscht
aber in seiner eigenen politik zunächst
mal stimmen gewonnen hat in dem eher
gespalten hat und das halte ich für ein
großes problem wir können das natürlich
versuchen in wahlkämpfen nüchtern
einzuschätzen und sagen wir wissen dass
sowas auf den plakaten steht wo es nicht
dass sein was dann später gemacht wird
aber wenn das so tief geht und wenn
solche gegensätze beschworen werden dann
wird daraus denke ich auch für die zeit
danach ein großes problem da kann er tun
was er möchte
er wird nicht gänzlich davon abstand
nehmen können wie er zu seinen stimmen
bekommen ist diese spaltung der
gesellschaft in 50 50 anteil eine starke
nutzer emotionalisierte spaltung in
wertefragen sehen wir nicht nur den usa
wir sehen sie auch am beispiel des brh
exit wir sehen sie in frankreich wir
sehen sie teilweise auch in deutschland
an der flüchtlingskrise und da kann man
sich natürlich fragen ist bei solch
einer kulturellen situation in der sie
ganz stark aufgeladene 50 50 kontraste
haben konsens überhaupt noch ein diskurs
ziel ist konsens da noch die sache die
eine demokratie zusammenhalten kann ich
glaube als in amerika länder dass europa
vielleicht zu stark immer auf konsens
gesetzt wird und ich denke wenn ich
welche europäische politiker diskutieren
sie denken diskutieren schon immer so
als seien sie potenzielle koalition zur
körper also ein kollege von uns liegt
als lohmann hat man gesagt ist es auch
eine tugend an die funktion von wahl
situationen von wahlkämpfen zu
polarisieren und ich denke das ist nicht
trumps persönliches verdienst aber dass
in dieser wahl und das in wahlen in
europa im letzten jahrzehnt oder noch
weniger jahren bestimmte soziale
bedürfnislage bestimmte ressentiments
sichtbar geworden sind das ist erstmal
keine schlechte situation also ich denke
dass es ein bewusstsein der probleme
dieser sich deklassiert für den
amerikaner gibt ist bedeutend und man
soll es nicht nur deshalb mehr glaube
ich eine einleiten gesagt nicht nur als
bedrohung auf fast entschuldigung aber
ich denke auch das es geht um eine
spaltung der gesellschaft und das
problem ist aber dass wir sozusagen vor
staatlich eigentlich keine politische
gemeinschaft mehr haben in diese
spaltung
und dieses building wird people nacht
will das ist das was wir jetzt erreichen
müssen und was erreicht wenn muss das
heißt nicht konsens das kann heißen auch
im streit nach den besten lösungen und
den westen zukunftsperspektiven sich
zusammenzusetzen
natürlich muss es eine basis geben und
bei vielen heterogenität geht es
diamanten also und ich denke das ist
genau darum geht es sozusagen das
henne-ei-problem oder oder catch phan
thi thu
was ist zuerst das sagen die deutsche
gemeinschaft und dann und dann sozusagen
enorm die uns zusammenhalten oder wie
viel der hetero homo die sie brauchen
wir aber ich glaube das wird diese
fragen heute stellen müssen
wer sind wir wo wollen wir hin wir
wollen wir sein und das uns trotz aller
heterogenität eigentlich zusammenhält es
gibt große fragen jetzt bewusst sein
dass wir ein politisches system haben
das eben diesen gegensatz selbst schon
zur institutionellen voraussetzung hat
also zu einer demokratie gehört die
opposition gehört also insofern haben
wir ganz bestimmte einsichten in den
prozess der politik schon in diesem
system dass da jetzt so angefeindet wird
mit berücksichtigt und was meines
erachtens ein problem ist dass man unter
diesen bedingungen zu wenig sieht das
neben dem gegensatz neben der opposition
auch der kompromiss eine ganz
wesentliche aufgabe hat und das wäre
denke ich eine erläuterung wie man ohne
von oben herab zu reden einfach noch mal
geben muss und ich möchte noch ein
letzter sagen das war eine schöne formel
wir haben jetzt vielleicht nur noch den
willen aber keine vorstellung nur wir
können den willen nicht haben ohne
vorstellung und insofern möchte ich weil
mich das wirklich besorgt doch sagen
dass wir vor allem jetzt angesichts
dieses ergebnisses nicht anfangen den
universalismus als etwas abgrundtief
unverständliches so wird es dargestellt
sind in zeitungen anzusehen den brauchen
wir gerade unter den gegenwärtigen
bedingungen aber wir müssen auch
deutlich machen was er für uns gerade
auch angesichts seines großen wandels
der vielen viel abverlangt
darunter waschen darf ich da kurz
nachfragen weil sie sagt darin von
gemeinschaft zunächst nicht von
gesellschaft die sagten building the
people
der begriff des volks ist ja dann ganz
wichtiger begriff und er steht in einem
kontrast zum universalismus ist der
begriff des volks einer der diese
bindungskräfte schaffen kann
oder sollten wir sehr vorsichtig mit ihm
umgehen club ist ja umbenannt wurden von
als die mauer gefallen ist wir sind das
volk wir sind ein volk und der
populismus macht ja genau das sozusagen
sich als einziger alleinige stimme des
volkes als homogenes gebilde suggerieren
und das ist natürlich komplett ab die
demokratisch weil demokratie immer in
alternativen denken und eine pluralismus
zu lassen muss wie er gesagt hat das ist
auf jeden fall richtig
ob wir jetzt sozusagen uns anständig
machen sollten
das volk soll die realität ist volk es
nochmal durchzudeklinieren glaube ich
nicht aber was wir schon brauchen ist
genau wie die sagen einem
wiedererstarken des universalismus aber
wir brauchen die deutung der norm die
uns am ende auch zusammenhalten und das
hat natürlich setzt voraus dass wir eine
politische gemeinschaft haben die genau
das unternehmen in gemeinsamen sprechen
wir brauchen funktionierende
kommunikation ich denke wir haben es
kommunikationsstörungen zu tun und ich
glaube es geht nicht darum nur mit
diesen menschen die vielleicht weit weg
von uns sind zu sprechen sondern erst
mal zuzuhören ihr kollege jürgen weber
hat ein wunderbares buch geschrieben
zu fuß in einem nervösen land wo er
versucht mit den menschen ins gespräch
zu kommen und genau diese geschichten
erzählt und auf und einfach ihnen ihre
sorgen aufschreibt und das ist schon mal
ein schritt gewonnen weil sie eben auch
nicht einfach in schablonen mit anti
cavallis erkannt der kabbalistischen
sorgen und ähnliches zu verkürzen sind
da ist noch ganz viel mit ganz viel
widersprüche die nicht einfach
aufzulösen sind aber herum recht das
volk in amerika lippe ist dass überhaupt
eine erstens eine gute übersetzung und
zweitens ist das nicht ein wichtiger
bestandteil der amerikanischen sec
wollte sagen und das führt mich also in
eine nicht polemische aber erstmal
schwer aufzulösen die spannungen zu dem
was sie gesagt
realismus ich teile genau diese meinung
und zugleich denke ich gehört der
universalismus dem wir glaube ich hier
am tisch so wie es gemeint haben alle
bei stimmen würden
zu den problemen also mann sagte im
englischen
ich denke das sanierte eu sehr gut zeigt
ja ich glaube es gäbe keine katalanische
unabhängigkeitsbewegung wenn es nicht
die eu gebe weil man weil die eu
sozusagen von vielen als vorstellungs
raum nicht ausgefüllt werden können
das ist gar können betonte
differenzierung dann ist erstmal das ist
zu abstrakt und in dieser hinsicht hat
diese slogan in der kombination mit
ersten person plural wii hat ja nicht
gesagt america grading das ist glaube
ich auch gar nicht notwendigerweise
polemisch und gegen den rest der welt
gesetzt sondern es an bezugsrahmen der
zum beispiel durch bisher nur eine
nationalsprache ich nehme an das wird
sich im nächsten halben jahrhundert in
der verfassung ändern es wird zwei
nationalsprachen geben
aber so eine gewisse einheits
vorstellung auf solche dinge wird vom
kommst du kommst ja bei einer internen
ausdifferenzierung und und ich sage
jetzt nicht dass unter steht im
widerspruch zum universalismus sondern
wenn es möglich wäre und vielleicht wäre
ein rückgang auf den foundation moment
an gründung der gründung der usa mobile
pippo aber the people steht im sinne
eines universalismus denke ich also in
der bill of rights dass das wieder
verwendet wird ist das amerikanische
volk meine ich als agent des
universalismus als agent universaler
welt wenn man auf diesen moment
zurückkommen könnte dann der an starken
der ein starkes positives partner sind
und vereinigten staaten hat das könnte
so eine
ich würde sagen gemeinschaft ist schon
wichtig denn antwort wäre gemeinschaft
geschrieben natürlich etwas anderer
konvention als volksgemeinschaft
in der tat geht es eigentlich um hat mit
einer anzusprechen und ihn aktivitäts um
neuanfänger ja also welchen attraktive
können wir jetzt in euro
auch sozusagen anfangen zu erzählen die
glaubhaft 10 und in der tat muss ich
ihnen recht geben ich glaube dass der
konsens und die alternativlosigkeit auch
genau zum exit geführt hat weil
sozusagen business as usual wollte
keiner mehr und wechselt war die einzige
möglichkeit eigentlich er seine stimme
zu erheben also brad pitt und war exit
und weiß wurden umgedreht die einzige
alternative zum bestehenden war
auszutreten
und ich glaube diese offenheit uns zu
erlauben auch einfach alternative
zukunftsvorstellungen und negative zu
entwickeln
dahin müssen wir kommen und das heißt in
der tat auch für europa live bibel
mögliche therapien pieper mit allen
sozusagen pluralistischen vorstellungen
wie das beinhaltet zu erzählen
aber ich hab es nicht eine ganz
kritische punkt denn der
rechtspopulismus der sich europa stark
ausbreitet man kann trump in dieses
muster einbinden man kann ihn ja als
globalisierungs allergie verstehen ja
als orientierung allergie gegen die
zumutungen der globalisierung und dann
ist die frage wie ist dieses wie
wirklich sinnvoll als die gesamte
erdenbürger schafft überhaupt zu fassen
politisch oder ist es nicht doch immer
lokal und kulturell angebunden
das ist es im ursprung natürlich aber
wenn wir sehen wie wir inzwischen auf
diesem globus kommunizieren wie wir ihn
nutzen für den handel für den urlaub und
für vieles andere
welche probleme er uns in der gesamtheit
macht ich will jetzt nur die
verschmutzung der meere annehmen dann
haben wir die großartige chance die wir
vorher in dieser form überhaupt nicht
hatten die gemeinsamkeit von problemen
der erdbevölkerung zu erfahren wir
diskutieren über klimawandel der alle
betrifft und insofern wenn sie mir
widersprochen hätten dann hätte ich das
gar nicht als widerspruch gewertet weil
es eben so ist das hier ganz bestimmte
termini die uns wichtig sind und die wir
verwenden wie zum beispiel den des
individuums oder aber auch den der
kommunikation oder aber auch den
gebrauch entsprechender geräte die die
uns heute jetzt weltweit erlebt gar
nicht nutzen könnten gar nicht einsetzen
könnten wenn ich zugleich immer
unterstellt werde
dass sie auf eine gesamtheit dazu sind
in der wir uns in irgendeiner weise
befinden und das kann natürlich
funktional eingeschränkt sein kann aber
gerade unter finde ich ihren hinweis auf
die gründungs situation der vereinigten
staaten sehr wichtig wir haben in europa
auch denke ich im topos der
französischen revolution seine momente
der brüderlichkeit die eben solche
einheit und solidarität angezeigt haben
das ist meines erachtens da bin ich mit
ihm ganz einig die aufgabe dies
verständlich zu machen und eben jetzt
nicht durch permanente belehrung sondern
eben dadurch dass man zeigt wie diese
dinge so zusammenhängen dass auch die
eigenen interessen unmittelbar betroffen
sind
ich wollte einfach sagen sie der frage
global lokal also wir sind im augenblick
dabei kommt 22 auszuhandeln marrakesch
das ist nach dem pariser abkommen zum
klima der nächste schritt
man ist interessant werden zu sehen was
de facto jetzt wirklich unternimmt wenn
wir sagen keinen globalen beratervertrag
hinbekommen und wir sind weit davon
entfernt
dann werden wir den klimawandel nicht
aufhalten können
aber die frage ist ja wie übersetzt sich
diese komplexen fragen und normen des
pariser abkommens in ganz klar
verständliche und auch lokal
angesiedelte fragen ja und ich glaube
diese übersetzungsleistung müssen wir
schaffen nicht nur von der globalen zur
nationalen sondern in die kommunen
hinein und das wird natürlich kommen die
nachhaltigkeitsziele werden übersetzt in
jede kommune
es wird darum gehen beispielsweise in
der lausitz und um arbeitsplätze einer
netz geht und um dekarbonisierung
möglicherweise auf der anderen seite
steht im widerspruch video sich das auf
wie kann ich alternative zukünfte ein
anderes wirtschaftsmodell überhaupt
entwickeln das kann ich nur mit den
leuten das kann ich nicht über ihre
köpfe hinweg und deshalb müssen die
vorstellung der leute ansprechen also in
der lausitz nicht von der verschmutzung
des pazifik reden wir von der funktion
des pazifik ich wir uns zehnmal vom
pazifik weg und kann mir die lausitz so
ganz schwer vorstellen also das ist
genau der punkt
und insofern
das war mir vor beginn oder diskussion
ich so klar also dieser eben
amerikanischen vater dem französischen
fall im deutschen fall gibt zumindest
ein problem er sie sind foundation
moment of democracy das ist 1948 49 hier
geboren wurden ungefähr aber es gibt
sozusagen fall hätte so hätte es werden
können ist nicht geworden aber schweiz
kein ähnliche gründungsmoment also
dieser moment in dem la nacion in
frankreich the people zugleich und das
scheint mir die show zu sein zugleich im
sinn von scale von größe die nation ist
aber die nation versteht sich als
verkörperung nicht bewusst verkörperung
nicht nur als repräsentation als
verkörperung und über seine werte das
ist sozusagen ein emblem und ein rahmen
für die vermittlungsleistung von die
sich von der 7 konkreten reden darf ich
noch mal auf die veränderte
kommunikation city so zurückkommen wir
wollen ein globales bewusstsein schaffen
wir haben eine globale kommunikation
situation über soziale netzwerke über
medien
wir haben aber auch eine andere zeit
logik sie sagen es schon wir haben ja
hier einen präsidenten der die gesamte
welt per twitter innerhalb von zwei
sekunden erreicht und einen resonanzraum
schafft indem er unmittelbar
rückmeldungen erhält
meine frage an sie drei ist die zeit
logik dieser neuen medien vernunft
fördernd im diskurs oder ist die
vernunft zerstörend schwierige frage
wenn ich das sagen darf und zwar deshalb
weil wir und das soll jetzt auch nicht
von oben herab als philosoph in dieser
runde gesagt sein weil wir bewusstsein
schon gar nicht verstehen wenn es nicht
ursprünglich darauf gerichtet es im
prinzip von allen verstanden zu werden
und insofern das war meine formel vor
jahren dass das bewusstsein selbst nicht
eingeschlossen in unserem kopf so
subjektiv ist sondern selbst schon für
das vorsichtig sagen auf dem weg in die
öffentlichkeit ist und öffentlichkeit
unterstellt
das heißt aber dass es keineswegs
ausgeschlossen ist in einer solchen
runde zu sprechen wir können auch gleich
noch weiter sprechen wir das
die kamera wieder aus ist man kann
natürlich einzelne einheiten schaffen
und damit müssen wir immer rechnen
der stammtisch ist sozusagen out aber es
gibt jetzt ganz andere
kommunikationsmedien und da kommt es
sehr darauf an dass wir die selbst
nachvollziehbar und öffentlich machen
das halte ich für ganz außerordentlich
wichtig damit die sich nicht isolieren
und verselbstständigen sondern es muss
das bewusstsein entstehen dass dies
tatsächlich kommunikations weisen in
einer globalen zusammenhang der nur
unter universalistische voraussetzungen
gegeben sein kann
also ich denke schon dass wir es auch
mit einem umbruch bis zeit regimes zu
tun haben
vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft die die
kampagne von franck hat gezeigt dass der
präsentismus radikal geworden ist nicht
nur so kann die nächste umfrage und die
gegenwärtig die gegenwärtigkeit also die
nächste bilanz sondern wirklich der
eigenen der moment und sicherlich haben
die sozialen medien sind diese
schnelligkeit noch verstärkt im habitus
da bin ich mir ganz sicher
und das geht euch im widerspruch zu den
komplexität von herausforderung mit
denen wir es zu tun haben so schnell
lösungen eben auch nicht zu erwarten
sind wo wir dinge erst einmal
durchdenken müssen und auch keine short
cuts uns erlauben können populismus
macht ja genau das short cuts im
verhältnis zu komplex die kürzungen er
abkürzungen im verhältnis zu den
operationen in den parlamenten also ein
mühsames geschäft fahren von von
kompromissen
durch unseren exekutiv lastige politik
und sozusagen business as usual wird ja
genau das ausgehebelt und die menschen
empfinden das als solches sondern haben
wir auch über den klimawandel gesprochen
wir müssen heute langfristige zukunft
bedenken jetzt nicht in
legislaturperioden von 45 jahren
diese wir brauchen ein neues zeit regime
wo sozusagen auch die motorisierung von
politik in das system eingebaut werden
muss dass eines der forschungsprojekte
pss habe ich denke wir haben es mit
einer tektonischen veränderungen des
zeitraums zu tun aber diese foto
regierung ist ja um eine ermutigung in
einer gesellschaft ja das klassische
moderne bewusstsein alles könnte anders
sein
ich kann aber nichts ändern das ist ja
auch ein aspekt dieses euro
ich möchte ganz kurz auf diesen punkt
angehe und dann noch mal auf einem
zwinger kommen und die frage ob es eine
schwere frage ist diese gegenwärtigkeit
diese betonung der gegenwärtigkeit
unvernunft ob die im widerspruch steht
oder nicht also zunächst was die zukunft
angeht glaube ich dass wir einen
problematischen situation uns befinden
weil die zukunft welche
parlamentarischen demokratie notwendig
voraussetzt nämlich wies koselleck ein
deutsche geisteswissenschaftler
beschrieben hat zukunft erscheint seit
der aufklärung als ein offener horizont
von möglichkeiten den wir gestalten
sollen und jede wahl und dieses
wahlplakat setzt das voraus also der
berühmte satz yes we can von obama dann
kann man so unterbringen das ist immer
noch möglich wir können immer noch die
zukunft gestalten der zweiten obama
kampagne kann dieser satz nicht mehr vor
denn ich glaube dass die zukunft mit der
wir aufwachen und uns die zähne putzen
eine zu also nicht nur die zähne putzen
eine zukunft ist die besetzt ist von
gefahren die langsam aber unvermeidlich
auf uns zukommen
global warming erschöpfung der rohstoffe
demografische entwicklung ich behaupte
ja nicht dass ich im tierisch beurteilen
können ob das objektiv sei aber das ist
eine zukunft in der es immer nur etwas
zu retten gibt oder zu verlangsamen gibt
dass er das eine was ich sagen wollte
das andere
wenn man davon ausgeht und ich denke
wenn das teil dass man die performance
an den gebrauch von vernunft mit
argumentation verbindet das bedeutet
argumentation immer weil männer dann
auch bwb danach und so weiter ist eine
native struktur eine syntaktische
struktur und die meine steht in einer
spannung zu der gegenwart betonen diesem
präsentismus kann jetzt sagen der durch
die elektronischen medien gefördert wird
und der im zentrum eines wahlkampf steht
der auf resonanz aus ist ja ich meine
das ist der punkt man hat bei den tramp
hillary diskussion am fernsehen gesehen
das trampen für die ersten 20 minuten
waren
wieder ein bisschen argumentieren für
seine verhältnisse und dann gab es
irgendeinen punkt in dem es keine
argumente mehr gab es keine argumente
mehr ab so dass ich denke dass nicht die
vernunft als prinzip würde nicht sagen
die sie ganz krise aber sozusagen die
praxis der vernunft die sich im argument
vollzieht in kompromissen vorzieht schon
unter druck steht
aber sie haben ja sehr viel auch über
stimmung unter den griff der stimmung
geschrieben was auffällt dass in diesen
digitalen kommunikationsprozessen die
stimmung der gereiztheit der
angreifbarkeit und das angegriffen
werden sich sehr stark manifestiert das
sind gereizte räume und sind es dann
überhaupt räume in denen sich das was
öffentliche vernunft sein soll
manifestieren kann ich denke das ist
natürlich die öffentliche hat sich stark
verändert nicht im verhältnis zur 60er
jahren strukturen der öffentlichkeit
sondern auch den letzten 10 20 jahren
die sozialen medien machen ja folgen
dass man eben schnelle reaktion bekommt
dass man aber auch nur mit
seinesgleichen sprechen kann das heißt
es gibt eine zersplitterung die
hochgefährlich ist und die
ursprünglichen institutionen die ja
früher so was wie eine meinung oder oder
willensbildung überhaupt formiert haben
also natürlich die parteien aber auch
die medien die kirchen die
gewerkschaften haben diese funktion
heute nicht mehr
die haben aber auch standards gesetzt ja
ich kenne leute und habe mit leuten
gesprochen in europa in amerika die
überhaupt keine zeitung lesen auch nicht
mehr fern schauen sondern ihre gesamten
informationen nur noch über über
facebook erhalten teilweise von
ungeklärten quelle wo sie die fakten her
haben ja und das ist hochgefährlich und
dieses heißt es eine krise derjenigen
institution die so was wie eine
öffentlichkeit noch zusammengehalten
haben und den müssen wir irgendwie
gerecht werden es gibt nicht nur und
aber auch eine regulierung des internets
und da gibt's ja auch verschiedene
ansätze und und sozusagen politische
vorstellungen aber auch wir müssen
überlegen wie das zu einer
demokratischen öffentlichkeit überhaupt
wieder zusammengeführt werden kann und
welche stand wäre die stadt setzt wie
weit entfernt er spricht mit sie wird
das genauso sehen
und nur daran erinnern dass wir uns
nicht dadurch schwächen lassen sollten
indem wir diese probleme als vollständig
neu darstellen und sondern viel eher
davon ausgehen dass das gereizte
zeitungslesern die kann ich mich sehr in
wieder da auf das blatt schlugen und
sagen jetzt sagen die wieder diese hunde
also gereiztheit gibt es dort wo
gegensätze sind
um missverständnisse entstehen natürlich
immer jetzt sind sie aktualisiert das
ist in der tat ein neues phänomen
und für mich ist die frage ob es nicht
doch gelingen könnte durch das was im
politischen prozess bereits unter
begriffen steht nämlich dass sie eben
nicht nur von nationen von völkern
sondern eben auch von föderalen von
kleineren einheiten auch von kommunalen
einheiten sprechen und was eben durch
den anderen begriff der subsidiarität
schon gegeben ist und was viel stärker
praktiziert werden muss eben einbeziehen
das politisch in europa ist das denke
ich eigentlich das zentrale problem dass
sie einheiten zu groß sind
aber der zusammenhang im ganzen
wichtigen fragen dann zum teil ebenso
umständlich gesucht werden muss dass er
gar nicht mehr zustande kommt oder dann
schon wieder vergessen ist dass wir dies
in einer regulierung der digitalen
kommunikation versuchen somit umzusetzen
dass eben diese ansprache durch die mit
denen man kommuniziert wieder möglich
fertig weiß dass das jetzt dazu
fantastisch klingt aber wenn wir das
nicht wenn wir das nicht versuchen dann
denke ich gibt es diese autoritative
öffentlichkeit sozusagen die
öffentlichkeit der vernunft war dann
gibt es sie mit sicherheit nicht mehr
sie wollten dazu kann ich ja also wir
sprechen ja nicht ausschließlich vom
schweizer publikum aber doch großen teil
vom schweizer publikum und ich denke
dass ich bin nicht daran sie der meinung
ist es gibt eine reihe interessanter
parallelen ähnlichkeiten zwischen der
schweizer struktur demokratie und der
struktur demokratien vereinigten staaten
die beide zu den ältesten demokratien
das muss man dobermann
als amerikaner in dieser traurigen
momentanen situation sagen was ich meine
ist jetzt das ist eine tradition des
lokalen gibt wenn ich gefragt werde wo
wohne ich dann sage ich oft ich wohne in
santa clara county und dann in
california und auch noch ein regional
die states of america
es ist jetzt habe ich bei ihm nicht wahr
in europa in dieser woche wahrgenommen
ich bin zu allem an einer reihe von
townhall meetings eingeladen
das ist eine ganz alte demokratische
institution man trifft sich und es
sollen sich eigentlich alle treffen
nicht nur die wälder von hillary clinton
oder wähler von trump haus aus der blase
sozusagen die situation also das sind
das sind 300 leute oder das ist nicht
mal palo alto die gemeinde wo ich wohne
von 66.000 einwohner sind das erinnert
mich an die schweiz das erinnert mich an
bestimmte befragungen und das könnte
auch so eine chance sein denn dieser
diese struktur
es gibt dann wird die welt klappt ja das
sind strukturen die schon immer das
pathos des gründungs moment haben wir
erinnern an diese glücklichen es ist
auch die 50er jahre sind sicher dominant
aber in einer vagen weise ist natürlich
auch der foundation moment 1774 meister
sind ja genau die formate wenn ich es
richtig verstehe über bürgerdialoge die
sie auch vorschlagen als eins der
heilmittel für die gegenwärtige
situation
das ist sicherlich kein heilmittel für
jetzt die den schwarzen mittwoch den wir
jetzt irgendwie gerade überlebt haben
aber ich denke schon das ist eine große
fraktion gibt auch von usa townhall
meetings bürgerdialoge die frage ist was
da genau passiert und warum sie diesen
diesen wie soll ich sagen diesen reiz
haben für bürger
sie hatte nicht vor der öffentlichkeit
gespannt ich glaube es gibt einen
fundamentalen unterschied heute zu früh
die bereits ab gab es auch vorher aber
die selbst über krämpfe erfahrung von
von usern gab es früher nicht
also ich hatte mit schirmherrin
diskussion wo ich mir sagte wenn ich in
artikel über acta schreiber das war die
möglichkeit sozusagen daten politik auf
zu betreiben auf europäischer ebene habe
ich innerhalb von drei stunden einen
shitstorm von irgendwie 200.000
kommentaren
das ist schon ein großer unterschied zu
früher und das
heißt aber auch dass sowohl das internet
als auch die generelle erhöhung der
bildung im durchschnitt natürlich gibt
es diejenigen die abgehängt sind aber im
durchschnitt generelle erhöhung der
bildung dazu geführt dass die bürger
eine unglaubliche beteiligungs erwartung
haben und auch jetzt der ruf nach den
ganzen direkt demokratischen
abstimmungen in deutschland genau führt
er zeigt das ja auch die frage ist wie
kann man dieses bereitschaft sich zu
engagieren auch gerade auf lokaler ebene
da macht es ja am meisten sinn wie ich
aufholen sagt wie kann man globale
herausforderungen in der lokalen
gemeinde und sagen übersetzen und welche
herausforderung gibt es da vor ort
das muss genau in diesen art von gremien
auch sollte meine sachen gemacht werden
wo man eben auch eine
zukunftsperspektive beispielsweise die
zukunft retten das ist eine idee die ich
mit claus leggewie entwickelt habe wo
man eben zukunftsfragen übersetzt in
einem gremium von von bürgern die
kontinuierlich an diese fragen arbeitet
als ideengeber der gemeinderäte keine
ausführung der repräsentativen
demokratie also ich nehme auch war das
angesicht von angesicht sei auch eine
ganz andere funktion für demokratie als
dieses digitale sprechen ich glaube da
sind wir uns alle einig wir haben jetzt
noch eine minute
und wir haben einen gast der morgen
zurück nach amerika fliegen darf
vielleicht auch muss wie ist ihr gefühl
jetzt in dieser rückkehr dieses land und
auch die frage wie es in der lage zu
sagen
donald trump ist mein präsident es ist
auch mein präsident
ja ich werde sorgen und wir erklären wie
ich das meine ich meine das im sinn
eine anerkennung eines franz der
konstruktion die meine ich dass ich bin
auch nicht der einzige aus meint eine
der ganz großen konstruktion also
verfassung der der weltgeschichte ist
das modell auch zum beispiel für die
deutsche verfassung und ich denke wenn
ich sagen würde
auf die frage hin das ist nicht mein
präsident bitte das zuerst bedeutet ich
erkenne die verfassung nicht
insofern werde ich da hin reisen und ich
bin etwas optimistisch weil ich diese
einladung per e mail
murdochs einer weise zu trauern horn
meetings nicht erwartet hätte und meine
hoffnung ist dass nach dieser wahl die
deklassierten leute plötzlich stolz zu
den town hall meetings kommt ob das der
fall sein wird weiß ich nicht aber es
könnte das
also gesehen optimismus wir sehen
hoffnung im gespräch ich hoffe wir
konnten etwas davon heute verkörpern
denn wir suchen ja alle noch nach
gedanken und orientierung in dieser zeit
hat sich ein dank franz hat sehr gute
lösung
herzlich danke dass sie heute hier waren
nächste woche sprechen über den
krisenherd türkei unter anderem mit der
türkischen vestel autorin ilicak sie
wurde 2006 wegen ehrverletzung des
türkentums angeklagt lässt sich aber
nicht einschüchtern
jetzt gleich kommt erst mal alles zu
einem guten ende
wenn noch im letzten moment der film
song of lahore zeigt mutige
pakistanische musiker die trotz
musikverbot im versteckten weiterspielen
und dann mit dave brubecks take five die
welt erobern
eine beeindruckende und wahre geschichte
hören sie zu und auf wiedersehen